former House Speaker Newt Gingrich Fox
News contributor and host of the new
podcast newts world
all right speaker you and I've been in
runaround Washington for a long time
watching these various debates the
culture wars and so forth why are the
Democrats continuing to have this blind
spot on where many in the middle reside
on issues such as the issue of life no
look but I think that the true faith of
the left one of the Democratic Party is
now in full blossom I think they get
together in meetings talk to each other
go out to fundraisers with people who
agree with them and you know convince
themselves for example as you pointed
out I mean I if you had ever said to me
five ten fifteen years ago that we would
be approving infanticide and as you
point out the New York legislature would
be applauding and cheering that they
passed the right to kill babies after
they're born this is grotesque and most
Americans don't agree with it but among
the hardcore left on issue after issue
after issue they believe things that I
think personally are crazy and that I
don't think the American people will
endorse and I think it may set up in
1972 George McGovern disaster where they
end up so far out on the left-wing limb
that people decide they just can't vote
for him I think going back to Phyllis
Schlafly and the Equal Rights Amendment
you know she successfully led the effort
to kill the e ra I remember reading
about how the Democrats back then
thought oh we got him now what we're
going to Bank wish the Republican Party
forever and what happened a few years
later Ronald Reagan was elected so I
mean they've been they've been hitting
the same drum for decades about the
social issues but these social issues
don't go away the Democrats just keep
moving further and further to left look
if I was in California over the weekend
talking to people and the number of
women who came up to me and said they're
really worried because they think their
daughters are not going to be able to
have a successful women's sports program
because of the drive of the Democrats to
basically allow transgender males to
dominate women's sports and I don't
think people have realized yet what an
assault this is going to be oh my god on
women and on their right to compete but
that's the sort of thing you're not
going to get Vogue magazine to print and
you're not going to get the New York
Times to print and that's why it takes a
while the country gradually recoils
after the left-wing establishment has
done all it could and I think you're
going to see that kind of recoil on
eight or ten or twelve issues this focus
this coming year yeah I think you can
kind of picture new Trump looking at his
Democratic opponent and saying now your
party actually passed legislation in the
house that would compel girls in a
locker room to welcome a biological male
in the locker room while they're getting
ready for their sports or leaving the
locker room that that would be compelled
by federal law right I mean Trump's
never gonna let them weasel well I
believe in choice no no you want boys to
shower in the same blocker room as girls
because that's what the legislation
mandates right and they're gonna have to
answer that question
look look then in Connecticut to
transgender males one the the women's
sports event that I have for the state
championship and you know and then let's
be clear about this this is the most
bizarre reversal of all the principles
of a fifty year fight for women's rights
feminists you've ever seen I mean you're
presently going to have a transgender
male soccer team I mean it's crazy in
terms of what what does all this do to
women's rights to be able to compete and
to be able to be involved that's in an
environment where they actually have a
reasonable chance to win well they're so
twisted up in knots and radicalism I
don't think I don't think they know how
to unknot themselves at this at this
point by the way knew this was
wunderkind mayor a Pete Buddha judge at
the Supreme Court rally today on
abortion I think
it's just one more example of a majority
of Americans agree on something and
there's a lot of extremism in the
Republican Party that's forcing
moderates to ask whether the Republican
Party has left them behind extremists in
the Republican Party really I don't know
how to explain - I don't know how to
explain to the mayor that the
overwhelming majority of Americans about
eighty-one percent are opposed to
killing babies after they're born that
the positions he's taking are very
minority positions and I think that
again again you have the same
conversation going on
you have left-wing Democrats going to
left-wing rallies to say left-wing
things the left-wing rally applauds
and then to compete the next person
comes in it has to be even more extreme
and that's what you have 20-some
Democrats now running wildly to the left
well and Newt
Kirsten Gillibrand is another individual
who's been trying to regain or or gain I
should say any traction in this very
crowded field and a lot of people
thought after the me to movement Harvey
Weinstein that that she would really
emerge from the pack but she's also
struggling she said this about an issue
near and dear to your heart the Hyde
Amendment let's watch you know we have a
tenant in our Constitution it's called
separation of church and state and I do
not believe that that is a valid
argument I think that the Hyde Amendment
should be repealed new the Hyde
Amendment so the Ingram angle audience
how radical that is if you want to
repeal that I'd love to do the national
polling on that look I think the item of
it goes back to the 1970s
and is a very simple statement no
American should be forced to pay taxes
to pay for an abortion it has been a
consistent position for now for over 40
years and again but it's where they're
going where they're going to say one we
have the right to kill a baby after it's
born - we have the right to charge the
taxpayer while we're killing the baby I
mean I mean think about this I think in
a very radical position Sanders Bernie
Sanders said the other day he didn't
mind if they had sex selection abortions
well with
means everywhere on the planet his girl
babies get aborted there's no question
statistically and you know if you permit
sex selection abortions there will be
far more abortions of females than males
and that's what Sanders said he was
willing to accept so they're kind
they're sort of caught right now in a
downward spiral not just on this issue
but in a whole range of issues where I
think that they're going to become
harder and harder to defend we played
the soundbite earlier new to the angle
just demonstrating how far left the
Democrats have been pulled now I think
Obama has always been there but the
party hasn't and so whether it's on the
question of gay marriage or or the issue
of abortion or now gender bending and
also I mean you got a you got a sense
that Biden is not comfortable with any
of this I mean he's got to be like
anyway they're my consultants are
telling me I've got to say this stuff
but my god I still got to go to Mass on
Sunday I'm still kind of like I still
gotta figure this out well look as you
point out earlier when you showed this
segment of Obama lying about his
position on marriage Obama was it was
always a radical who understood he
couldn't get elected as a radical so in
the classic tradition he pretended to be
moderate long enough to get elected but
but the thing to remember about Biden
and I've known Biden for a very long
time Joe Biden is so shallow that he
won't notice most of this he'll just
think it's kind of confusing and he'll
drift along being Joe Biden and if he
can get nominated will be by being this
nice Pleasant doofus who doesn't know
anything but he's not the other people
and I think that's what he's counting on
is being you know being the least
disgusting person in the field we're
almost out of time but the other issue
that we touched on last night was this
move against the founders this has been
bubbling up for some time pulling down
statues and so forth and everyone feels
better when you pull down a robert e lee
statue that's that's like that was a big
obsession last year in the year before
but now of course as predicted moving
against thomas jefferson the author of
the Declaration of Independence Buddha
jet says well we can rename our dinner
maybe because we have people evolved but
if you're gonna rename a dinner you know
not Jack
Jefferson Jackson Jackson Jefferson
renamed that why wouldn't you rename
schools boulevards and ultimately take
down statues I mean if a dinner is
objectionable what about a school name
okay one of the things I've concluded is
these people are now so radical we have
to take them head-on
this is left-wing fascist
totalitarianism this is an effort to
erase the memory of the United States
Thomas Jefferson is a fact he wrote the
Declaration independence he was the you
know he created the Democratic Party
ironically in terms of people who now
want to besmirch him he was
extraordinarily important in the
development of America but what you have
is a group of left-wing Democrats who
would like to erase all of our memories
of America they really died deep down
would like us to be Venezuela and I
think that it's remarkable and I think
we on the conservative side have to be
much tougher by taking them head-on and
saying what it is what it said is
exactly like the Taliban destroying the
two Buddhist statues that were there
were historic worldwide monuments and
you have people Pete pretends to he's
exactly like Obama he pretends to be a
moderate until you listen to him a
little bit and realize he's as radical
as anybody else yeah an extremist with a
you know moderate exterior or a mild
mannered exterior mr. speaker you were
so great we didn't even have time to get
into the Dems impeachment obsession but
they're not going anywhere with
impeachment at least in my view thank
you so much sir fantastic